- Good morning Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe.
And I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your
journey today's message
is prepare yourself for success.
Over to you Dr. Sunday Adelaja.
(rooster)
(music)
- Success is possible,
success is a reality.
But the fact is that only
people who are well prepared
get the blessings of success in life.
You know, it's like life is not fair
it is a (mumbles) in some cases.
If you look at it just from the surface.
And you think that, you see some people
who are making it, some people
who are doing a good job.
And some people who are
really making it in life.
And you think, what makes these people
better than the other people?
And it's like there's not
really any much difference.
But really, there is a difference.
If you see anybody that
is truly making it,
that is doing a good job,
it is only because it's
done something right.
And the major condition,
or the major thing
a person like that has done right,
is that they have gotten
themselves prepared
for this success that they now enjoy.
Only opportunities come
only to people who are prepared for them.
If you are not prepared for opportunities,
you will never see them,
you will think that there are
no opportunities around you.
People complain about the
countries they live in,
people complain about their leaders,
people complain about their environment,
and they all complain that
there are no opportunities
in their countries, or in their cities,
or from their leaders.
But really, even in those countries,
even in those cities,
there are people who are
having opportunities, who are, you know,
being entrusted by life, by
great positions of opportunities
because they are prepared for them.
- So if you want to be successful,
you have to do the work
to be prepared for when it comes to you.
Success doesn't just land on your lap,
opportunities don't just
open themselves up to you,
you have to do the work.
It doesn't come by just
sitting on the couch
and dreaming and thinking and hoping that
something's going to happen to you.
It happens because you are
out, and you are preparing
and you are doing the work.
So as an example, I look at Lily,
who was one of my salsa
instructors, still is,
and I offered her a full time
opportunity to quit her job
and start her own business
as a new potential speaker with me.
And I paid her to leave her job
so she can start this opportunity.
So she's getting paid to leave her job,
she's getting mentoring from
me to launch her own business
and a lot of people would think,
well how do I get that opportunity?
How do I get that chance to do it?
You're so lucky that you get this thing
that nobody else gets.
But she did the work to prepare for it.
She was putting in hustle
and energy and heart
and from one of the first
times that I met her,
and had our conversation,
I said, I want to do something with you,
we're going to figure out a way,
some kind of business to happen together.
And she might have thought I was crazy
the first time that we
had that conversation.
- During the meeting, he told
me that he really liked me
and he wanted to start some
sort of business with me.
So my first thought was, wow!
He is so nice.
And what an amazing
confidence booster for me.
- But she worked at it and she prepared
and she put in hours
and effort consistently
and that's the difference.
If you look at anybody
who's had major success,
look at anybody who you look up to,
as an entrepreneur, as an athlete,
as a singer, whatever you aspire to do,
there is always a ton of hard work
that goes alongside it.
You will not get the success you're after
by just sitting on the couch.
And when an opportunity does come to you,
you have to say yes to it.
Before I offered Lily this position,
I actually offered a different position
to somebody else.
To a guy who I was going to
start a marketing agency with.
And he said no, he said he
wasn't ready to quit his job.
And he didn't jump on that opportunity.
And so I had the space
to offer it to Lily.
If he said yes, to that
opportunity three months sooner,
I wouldn't have been
able to give it to Lily
because my time would have been taken up.
But he said no, he's down on his copa path
and Lily said yes.
So when those opportunities come,
and when they're scary,
and when you're not sure
how it's going to work out,
do you seize it or not?
Or do you live the rest
of your life in regret
wondering, what might have happened?
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious,
what is the thing that
you are doing consistently
to prepare yourself for success?
How much are you working on
your dream, on your goal,
every single day to make
sure that it happens?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to John Jenkins.
John, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
"Your One Word" and making that
Youtube video about it man,
I really appreciate it and
I thank you for the support,
I'm glad you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
(music)
- I wake up about 4:30 and 5:00
and between 5 and 5:15
I am working on email,
catching up on news, looking at the blogs,
looking at the different opinions.
Because people just don't sleep,
I mean they are working 24/7,
somewhere around the world
people are awake and working.
So have this constantly being bombarded
with requests, information,
or just sometimes news.
And so in the morning I wake up and I
you know, take care of my mind.
(music)
And then after that I work out
and that's taking care of my body.
And then I do meditate before I go to work
so that takes care of my soul.
In a business, it's like a war.
You have to be completely prepared.
And unless you have mind, body, and soul
really all ready for it, you
just can't fight that battle.
- How often do you find
when you get on set,
people are like, do the Samuel,
do the Sam Jackson thing?
Do the Samuel Jackson thing
that we know and love?
- Not often.
- [Male Interviewer] No.
- I don't know what that is.
(laughing)
I mean,
unless you say motherfucker
like eight times.
(laughing)
You know, well crafted play.
(cheering)
But umm..
Yeah I don't, I don't
really know what that is
or to me, the Sam Jackson thing is
I've read the script, you know,
I don't know how many times
and I've broken my character down
the way I've learned to
break a character down
in the theater.
If there's source material, like for
George Washington Williams,
I'll go through the source
material and deal with that,
but if not, then, okay, it's up to me
to figure out who this guy is.
I can figure out when he was
born, who his parents were,
what his educational background is.
Military, if he has that.
What kind of life experiences he's had,
how he feels about
this, that or the other.
Even down to sometimes what
kind of food he eats, you know.
Just because there are
eatin scenes in the movie
and I want to figure out
what I want to eat, you know
when I'm in that particular scene.
And then, from scene to scene,
what my relationship is
with those characters,
or what I'm trying to
accomplish in this scene
that leads to the next scene,
that leads to the next scene
that leads to the next scene.
So, what happens is, the
Sam Jackson thing, for me
according to my agents and managers is
I'm so prepared, when I show up, that
I expect everybody else
to be as prepared as I am.
So when the director does not
have a shot list for that day,
or directors floundering
and trying to figure out
what he's doing, he can
ask me and I can tell him.
You know, because one of the
funny things about movies is
the directors usually the
person on the film set
that's got the least amount of experience
of everybody there.
(laughing)
- A director makes one
movie every four years,
every two years...
- But director's career is what?
A good director's career is 15 movies.
You know, everybody
there has done 15 movies
the last two years.
You know, so, we all know, you know
why the fuck he using that, that
ain't going to be in the movie
(laughing)
It's like, you don't
really need that shot.
(coughing)
(laughing)
So, there's that shit goin.
Where did I digress from?
- No that was amazing (mumbles)
I don't care that we digressed.
- I show up prepared.
So that's the Sam Jackson thing.
When you hire me, you hire an
actor who going to show up,
who going to know his lines,
who going to hit his marks
and do his best to make the other actors
around him better.
- [Interviewer] Absolutely.
- I'm not going to call shots for you,
and I don't expect you to
give me a line reading.
And if you do, you hired
the wrong motherfucker.
(laughing)
- With doubt, which
might be the first time
that people in film, necessarily really
appreciated what you were doing.
(clapping)
Your preparation for that
was astronomical, amazing
and, so the last, as the
last pre-Help question,
if I can just ask you, just
to show the kind of work
that you're willing to do, for even,
I think it was eight
minutes of screen time?
Which was deservedly rewarded
with an Oscar nomination
but I mean, that is
not a ton to work with,
and yet, you made the most of it.
How did you, what did you
do to prepare for that one?
- Well, it's based on a
play, so I read the play
and after I read the play I said,
I don't even understand this woman.
I don't know why this
got all this attention.
This woman wants to sacrifice her son,
and duh duh duh duh dah.
And I had all the kind of
responses that you would have
with character that you didn't understand.
But, it's being an actor, you
have to do investigative work.
You have to, you have to,
make sure that when people
are in the audience, they understand you.
And they ultimately feel something.
And so, I had to write a bio,
which ended up being over 100 pages.
I talked to people who had seen the play,
cause I was doing a play at the same time
and never saw the play.
I read the script, probably,
I don't know how many times.
So I literally studied
the script for four months
before I finally got it,
like I had the aha moment.
And the aha moment, is,
we always want to feel
that decisions are pretty.
We always want to believe
that decisions are easy.
And sometimes there are so fews choice.
You know, and sometimes
a person's motivations
are absolutely pure.
But to the outside eye, they
look very dysfunctional.
And I probably, you
know, had the aha moment
two days before I even started filming
and I was really waiting
for that aha moment
cause I said, I'm going to
be opposite Meryl Streep
and she's going to tear me a new a-hole.
And I do not want to look bad.
So I had that aha moment.
But I did my, I did my work with that.
I can't emphasize that enough, you know,
because I never want
anyone to dismiss my talent
listen, I may get up on this screen
and there are times when I may stink
because it's occupational
hazard to not always be good.
But I never want anyone to
say that she's not an actress.